watch OS TV OS OS 10 iOS we're gonna
move each of these platforms for today
Apple kicked off its Developers
Conference with the new watch OS and the
biggest news of the day
Minnie Mouse is now a watch face
seriously though
watch OS get several performance boosts
and feature enhancements your favorite
apps will now launch much faster
hey guys ready okay don't blink
that's it and the app previews are live
so you can see them and launch them all
from the same place there's also a new
way to write on the watch it's called
scribble and it's a lot like graffiti on
the Palm Pilots of old as expected Siri
will get some enhancements in the
updated version of TV OS just ask and
Siri will search from 650 thousand
movies and no more searching for that
tiny Apple remote in the couch cushions
now the iPhone app comes with all the
features found in the hardware remote
it'll use the phone's mic for Siri
queries use its sensors for motion
controls and games and offer a touchpad
interface Apple's also fixing the
authentication problem in TV OS single
sign-on lets you log into every app or
channel just by signing in once say
goodbye to OS 10 say hello to Mac OS the
new name of Apple's desktop operating
system with the name change comes a
bunch of improvements but the biggest
one Siri is coming to your Mac how do
you like being on a Mac pretty awesome
lots of space aluminium unibody walls
and no complaint about the lack of
Windows
this could mean the end of using the
finder to scour your hard drive
finally iOS 10 brings ten major upgrades
to your phone
Apple's biggest iOS release to date
notifications are improved Apple music
looks better and there's a lot more you
can do with maps like order food and
Halon uber but the biggest news is that
I message is now a media rich
communication platform mini-videos giant
emoji and more group messaging features
Apple's texting app is also open to
developers now but contrary to the
rumors of the last few weeks
iMessage is not coming to Android thank
you very much and have a fantastic week